it was another action-packed day of  chess960 where creativity and  originality get rewarded from the very  first move the best players in the world  had a new mystery to solve  as they wrestled with a novel  mind-bending setup at the start of the  game former world champion Garry  Kasparov scored a nice win but still  trails big against world number 2  Fabiano Caruana while Wesley sole played  a crushing attacking game against  Veselin Topalov and is running up the  score in their match there'll be more  thrills and spills as the great chess  gladiators trying to find their footing  on uncertain ground day three of  exciting action coming up next